SPEAKER: Hi, I'm [INAUDIBLE].
And today, I'm super
excited to talk
about securing your APIs using
Google Cloud's Apigee and Cloud
Armor.
Let's get to it.
So why are APIs so great?
Well, APIs significantly
reduce the time
to market of new
innovations and experiences
by providing a simple and
easy way for developers
to consume data
and functionality
that resides in your
backend systems.
Because APIs are packages of
business critical-information,
they're also targets
for malicious attacks.
Google Cloud Apigee also
saw over 170% increase
in abusive API traffic
in the past year.
To help you protect APIs
against security threats,
Google Cloud brings together
Apigee and Cloud Armor,
the best of API management
and web application firewall
solutions.
While Apigee offers OAuth, API
keys and role-based access,
and many other API-level
security features,
Cloud Armor offers network-level
security such as DDoS
protection, geo-fencing,
and mitigation
of OWASP top 10 risks.
Let's see a quick demo
of how this works.
For the purpose of this
demo, I have created
a Hello, World API in Apigee.
To protect this API, let's first
start by adding a verify API
key policy to this proxy.
Once we do that,
you'll see the default
is set to a query param.
Let's change this to a header.
I'm now going to save
it as a new revision.
And deploy it to the
demo environment.
To consume this API, let's
create an API product
and add our API proxy to this
product by specifying the path.
With this, the
Hello, World proxy
is now ready and accessible.
When I try to access
this API proxy,
Apigee would block it since
we didn't pass an API key.
Malicious clients could
still send a lot of requests
and interrupt traffic
processing by the gateway
for legitimate users.
So to further
protect this API, I
created a very basic
Google in Cloud Armor
for the simplicity of this demo.
This rule checks for
the API key header,
though it doesn't validate
the actual key itself.
I'm now going to apply this rule
to the Apigee load balancer.
And apply this
policy to the target.
Now, when I go to the load
balancing section under Network
services, and look into the
details of the load balancer,
I see that the security policy
has Cloud Armor attached to it.
Let's now try once
again to access
the same Hello, World API
without passing any API key.
You'll notice that the error
this time is at a network
level from Cloud Armor.
If the same API is accessed
with a header and an invalid API
key, then Cloud Armor
is going to clear it.
The Apigee would do
further validation
and block it due
to faulty API key.
That was just a
preview of how to add
multi-layer security
for your APIs
with Apigee and Cloud Armor.
In summary, Apigee and
Cloud Armor offer integrated
out-of-the-box box security
capabilities to protect
your APIs at multiple levels.
Now it's your turn
to try it out.
And get started by following
the links in the description box
below.
[MUSIC PLAYING]